more good news for vegas entertainment  magic mike live will reopen in march and  tickets are now on sale it's going to be  a new show in a new venue  it debuts this time at the sahara we  spoke to david terry he's one of the  performers  he said there's a lot of new elements  this time some inspired by the shows in  london  and berlin  the team with magic michael live  channing and  the production team have been really  really adamant about  creating just an entirely new show  that's  that kind of goes above and beyond um  what it was  and kind of reinventing the show to  still be creative  so the first show again march 26th  that's sahara las vegas  you can watch our full interview with  david it's on our website 8newsnow.com